I'm Park MacDonald and I was a co-winner
of the Nobel Prize in 2015 in physics
for observing that neutrinos changed
their flavour between being created in
the Sun and arriving at our detector on
earth the neutrinos are very penetrating
objects for them matter is open space
passing through every square centimeter
of your body every second there are a
few billion neutrinos from the Sun and
so they can travel through a million
billion kilometres of matter lead for
example with only a 50 percent chance of
hitting something that's a real
advantage if you want to study those
nuclear reactions that originate in the
core of the Sun when neutrinos are
produced in very large numbers it's a
disadvantage however when you try to
detect them and therefore we required a
detector that was the size of a 10-story
building and we had to situate it two
kilometers underground in a mine in
order that the rock above our detector
would stop other particles it's quite
ironic that you have to go way down into
the earth in order to study the Sun we
can use neutrinos to probe our universe
in various ways
we used them to probe the way in which
the Sun burns there was a puzzle because
too few neutrinos were being observed it
turns out we were able to demonstrate
that that is because the neutrinos
changed their flavour and therefore they
were being missed by other experiments
it gives us an opportunity to attempt to
understand our universe in a much more
complete way
we all want to
all of our food is safe but doing that
can be really hard looking for
contaminants in raw materials is tough
the statistics are stacked against us
today we can only test for pathogens
individually one sample at a time and
that means hundreds is not thousands of
tests most of which deliver a simple
negative result we needed to think about
this differently
that's why Mars and IBM join forces to
sequence the genomes of all the
organisms in the food supply chain
that's millions of organisms but big
data is what IBM is good at the DNA and
RNA sequences show you all the harmless
bacteria that are found in normal safe
food if we do the test and the
microorganisms are suddenly different
something's up the organisms have
changed because the environment has
changed it could be contaminated and not
only that this tells us things that we
never could have seen before like where
the food was grown how it was
transported and maybe even what happened
on route our approach to food safety
just got a lot smarter